just in case you guys want to know to
let you know how I feel about the alien
films I own the first two I don't have
the other ones
Prometheus is directed by Ridley Scott
star Charlize Theron Noomi Rapace Idris
Elba Michael Fassbender Guy Pearce a
great cast it's a film that exists in
the same universe as the original alien
films and that's all set in Prometheus
we have a group of people who've
scientists and explorers who are going
this far away place in space and they're
hoping to find the beings that
originated human life once they get
there stuff goes down that's all I'm
going to say Ridley Scott in a science
fiction world go hand in hand to me I
mean he is such a good director of
science fiction and he proves that again
with this movie this film is directed
the shot spanned along so nicely the
framing was excellent the special
effects are extraordinary the best
special effects are the kind of special
effects that blend CGI with practical
effects and you're not entirely sure
which is which sometimes and I've heard
a lot of things about Prometheus before
I saw because I didn't see it at a
screening like I usually do and all
these people are sending me messages so
Prometheus is disappointing Chris I was
disappointed with it didn't have enough
of this damn enough of that or I love
Prometheus it's a masterpiece you were
going to love it Chris you have to see
it now I hate hype like that I really
don't like knowing those types of things
like to go in completely blind and I
think there's a serious problem that
people are going into this movie
expecting something they're going into
this movie with expectations they're
expecting way too many times to alien
they're expecting creatures and
explosions and lots of action and
intense science-fiction you know fights
and nasty things if you go into this
movie with those type of expectations
not only is that not fair to the
filmmakers but it will set you up for
disappointment this is a wholly original
film that exists in the same world as
alien but you can't go into it with your
own expectations this is a movie that is
in my opinion a fantastic science
fiction film this is an excellent
excellent movie it has a lot of things
to say it leaves you with a lot of
different questions it's the kind of
movie that when you are done watching it
it's like you want to scour the IMDB
message boards and just ask questions
and debate with people and talk with
people to me this film is kind of like
the first alien
buying with 2001 a Space Odyssey it's a
film that has a lot of different things
to say about life but it's also a
thriller you know it's it's a scary film
at times it's suspenseful but you have
to go into this movie with an open mind
if you go into this movie with all of
your different expectations you're going
to be disappointed and it's not fair to
the filmmakers to have those type of
expectations so I will not be surprised
if anyone's disappointed with this movie
but I for one really liked it because I
appreciated what it was trying to say I
appreciated how it said it on a very
basic level this is an excellent looking
movie and sounding movie and really well
acted I really liked Noomi rapists in
this movie I thought she was great she
was a strong heroine she was an
interesting character I liked where she
went with the film I liked her questions
I liked how she was you know resourceful
similar to Ripley in the first alien
Michael Fassbender man Michael
Fassbender plays this Android character
he's one of the strongest points in this
movie I loved his character I loved how
without spoiling anything he just he had
his own thoughts about certain things
like he was an Android but you could
tell that he was an independent thinker
in some ways like he was curious you
know he wanted to figure things out for
himself there's a lot you seen the
trailer was holding like this little
speck of something and he's like big
things have small beginnings I was like
yeah they do Fassbender I saw a shame
fossum boner that's what I'm talking
about
I apologize the score is very good as
well this movie just sounds really good
it looks great there are a few problems
I had of this movie and largely they are
story based script based the set up the
plot of the film was done very quickly I
could tell the filmmakers just wanted to
get to space but you know some of it
just seemed a little weak another
problem I had of the film involves
spoilers which I will not say but there
is a bit of a unexpected thing that
happens in the third act of the film and
I felt like it was completely
unnecessary and didn't even need to be
in the movie I think if you look at this
film strictly as a sci-fi movie that has
things to say and says it in a beautiful
way you will be very impressed with this
movie don't go into this movie expecting
everything you want to see out of an
alien film because you will be
disappointed I think prometheus is an
excellent movie I think it's one of the
better movies I've seen all year I'm
going to give it an A - so what'd you
guys think of prometheus were you
disappointed by it is you loved it did
you go in with expectations do you feel
like maybe you shouldn't
have what do you think about prometheus
let me know below and as always guys if
you like this review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck mine eyes